es geht um politik es geht um den
bundestagswahlkampf es geht um armin
laschet es geht um die union aber es
geht vor allem um den kanzlerkandidaten
armin laschet und mich regt eigentlich
auch das tut es schon die ganze woche
dass die union weiterhin im schnarch
wahlkampf ist dass armin laschet
weiterhin nicht nach vorne kommt den
turbo zündet seit einer woche oder vor
einer woche muss man sagen gab es im
großen wahlkampfauftakt der union und
angela ascher hat versprochen und hat
gesagt ab jetzt geht's richtig los wir
zünden den turbo wir hatten heute
beispielsweise friedrich merz auch bei
bild live in der sendung und er hat auch
noch mal gesagt ja aber jetzt müssen wir
die ps auf die straße bringen wir hören
also seit einer woche es soll losgehen
es losgehen das ist nebelkerzen
wahlkampf denn es passiert nichts und
dieser nebelkerzen wahlkampf ist
eigentlich eine beleidigung für den
wähler wenn die union nicht aufhört und
nicht endlich loslegt dann wird sie
unter 15 prozent sinken da muss sie
möglicherweise sogar die fdp an sich
vorbeiziehen lassen also ich fordere
endlich einzusteigen wahlkampf damit die
bürgerinnen und bürger die wählerinnen
und wähler wirklich die chance richtig
zu entscheiden was gut ist für
deutschland und was nicht ja aber ich
bin seit 2010 cdu mitglied und werde
seitdem sei der wahlkampf begonnen hat
von der partei bombardiert mit hilfe wir
brauchen hilfe beim wahlkampf macht mit
nein meine antwort des jedes mal nein
ich würde diesen und
kandidaten und unterstütze diesen
kandidaten auch nicht ich werde laschet
nicht fehlen also ein cdu-mitglied und
ich werde diesen mann nicht mehr weil er
definitiv nicht der richtige für den
posten ist er ist keine führungskraft er
kann mich nicht vertreten und ich kenne
ganz viele cdu-mitglieder und cdu wähler
die genau das gleiche sagen was wäre
wenn wir jetzt olaf scholz nähe auf gar
keinen fall keiner der kandidaten ist
eigentlich wählbar habeck wenn die
werbung dort nicht sitzen würde wo sie
jetzt sitzt dank
ihres frauseins
hätte ich echt halle ich bin fange ja so
wählen er ist eine gute führungskraft da
steht zu seiner meinung damit kann ich
leben auch wenn er zugeben dass das
wissen das merkt man mal wieder in
diskussion
man muss noch nicht alles wissen man
muss nicht bis nach der anzahl menschen
die einen beraten aber das scheint man
kann nicht immer als allen auf
allwissend machen aber letztendlich
keine ahnung von nichts haben also was
ist ihre idee dass sebastian kurz jetzt
mit den grünen in österreich koaliert
nein aber ich war sehr froh darüber als
bekennende veganerin und tierschützerin
aber hier sehen wir ein problem wenn
vanier sogar eine bekennende cdu ein
cdu-mitglied jemand der den
konservativen werten
treu ist wahrscheinlich wenn sie
sebastian kurz beraten wenn sie auch für
schwarz-grün sind aber dennoch solche
probleme haben armin laschet zu wählen
oder sagen sie wollen ihn gar nicht
wählen als cdu-mitglied dann zeigt es ja
wie hoch und sind sie wahrscheinlich
nicht alleine sondern eine unter vielen
die ja die distanz ist von vielen in der
cdu in der csu wahrscheinlich noch umso
mehr gegenüber diesem spitzenkandidaten
und man stellt sich die frage hätte die
union nicht doch lieber markus
aufgestellt dann sehen sie jetzt
wahrscheinlich nicht bei 22 prozent in
puncto man muss sich das einmal
vorstellen diese
32,8 prozent bei der letzten
bundestagswahl
das war das schlechteste
nachkriegsergebnis der cdu überhaupt und
jetzt sind sie in den umfragen zumindest
kann man jemand trauen aber zehn
prozentpunkte darunter das ist schon
dramatisch und da muss man ja erst mal
wieder rauskommen auch entscheiden ich
muss ehrlich sagen aus rahden er ist
wird so viel auf laschet gerade
eingeschlagen dass er mein natürlicher
instinkt ist wird eine lanze
verteidigen würde auch keiner was heißt
sie den erfahrungen er regiert das
größte bundesland hat dort eine mega
strukturwandel zu bewerkstelligen gehabt
er hat erfährt im bundesland seit vielen
jahren das größer ist als so manches eu
mitglied der mann ist offenbar ein
konservativer der aber sehr wohl eine
fähigkeit nach zur mitte und zu grün hat
seine verpackung pragmatiker ich traue
ihm auch ehrlich gesagt zu ein
anständiges team zu sagen hast du ein
thema aber ich habe immer ein thema was
für was steht armin laschet ich würde
sagen auch für die gutes team um
aufbruchstimmung in diesem land
mir kommt auch mit wenig kommt mit stolz
als aufbruchstimmung nach der anderen
kommt der kölner
straße das thema gedacht wo sind denn
treten ja ich würde auch ist ich bin
hier auch bei alexander weil ich ganz
klar sagen muss ich traue armin laschet
zu dass er im team sich an die seite
holt er ist keine one gmbh wir trauen
das zu möglicherweise hat armin laschet
ich überzeugt aber wir sehen ja
22 prozent der wählerinnen und wähler
sagen derzeit noch das ein historischer
sich dabei hat das wetter weiterhin
weitere rhein zu den volksparteien ist
nein aber ich ja nicht das stimmt hier
einfach nicht wenn man unter schwesig
liegt in mecklenburg vorpommern bei 36
prozent die csu in bayern aus seinem
geliebten heimatland nicht ja nun auch
nicht bei 22 prozent es ist glaube ich
eine eine mehr zu sagen damit mache dass
ich auch ein ausnahme bela bitte stimmen
sie zu lösen und es ist doch damit dass
gottwald europa alle volksparteien in
der krise sind jede woche läuft ein
neuer über den haben wir dann bestiegen
bild persönlich bestimmer wir sehen doch
und sagen der der ist verantwortlicher
für eine andere ruinen des gesamten
vereins ist es deswegen lieber
mit einer krise in die nächste weil wir
nur berufspolitiker haben die seit
jahrzehnten irgendwas vor sich hin
lagern und aber eigentlich nichts
vernünftig umsetzen und die gesellschaft
immer noch immer mehr spalten ja nach
stadt wird sich ein team holen da sieht
man in nordrhein-westfalen super er hat
sich menschen mit muslimischen 5 nach
meiner meinung nach leicht
islamistischen background geholt und ist
jetzt natürlich integration meinen
kernthema und in der integrationsarbeit
wir total versagt weil der
integrationsarbeit findet mit die tib
und anderen inneren sicherheit wenn ihre
sicherheit ist zum beispiel ein voller
erfolg wem wird das abkommen geholt doch
schon mal was sagt man ideologisch er
fehler gemacht hat ist vollkommen klar
aber es zeigt schon mal dass da kein
ideologisches zeigt er hat er ist der
einzige der wirklich ein bundesland
geführt hat in der größe eines
unterstandes ins wahlkampfteam alex von
schönburg ins wahlkampfteam von einer
lagerhalle offenbar politik erklären
diese 22 prozent die komme nicht
zustande weil alle menschen sagen aber
dass du bist super hecht kommt zustande
weil es ganz viele menschen gibt die gar
nicht wissen was möglicherweise wenn du
recht hast armin laschet alles kann die
union du hast es gerade gesagt es steht
so schlecht da wie nie zuvor da kann man
jetzt nicht sagen was armin laschet für
ein toller typ ist sondern dann müsste
man sagen wenn man sympathie für armin
laschet hat der mann muss offenbar seine
wahlkampfstrategie ändern denn die union
stand unter seiner führung auch schon
mal deutlich besser aber hast du denn
rings parteien vor einem jahr stand die
union bei knapp 40 aber es zeigt
natürlich das vielleicht ist die zeit
der volksparteien noch nicht vorbei
sebastian kurz hat ähnliche
zustimmungsraten immer noch in
österreich also da gleichzeitig auch
eine normalität die absolut das ist so
erinnert euch endlich erinnere mich kann
ich meine spd-kandidaten der verkehr vor
paar jahren wo alle darüber gesprochen
auch so ähnlich wie scholz als marco hat
ein riesenhype
entstehen auch eigendynamik
es entstehen eigendynamik genauso wie
söder plötzlich ein album namens
20 prozent verteidigt ich glaube dass er
wenn du meine im sturm drinnen bist oder
in einer so und so ein wirbel bezieht
der dich weiter nach und dann sagen die
medien haben schauen wir wie bisher nach
unten wirbel dann gehst du weiter unten
und dann das das ist wenn er wieder
selbst erfüllende prophezeiung genau so
wie das jetzt mit stolz nach oben auch
einfach nur ein wieso ein windhauch ist
wenn er mich jetzt gegründet aber es ist
plötzlich so der der wind drehte schöner
es wir müssen gleich die fragen einen
anbieter noch jeden fall der seo des
parks machen wenn die wahlkampfberater
von angela ich würde an mich glauben und
wird jemanden suchen er hatte ein tolles
team auch offiziell benannt friedrich
merz so wird gemeinsamer auftritt machen
würden märz noch bei anschicken nach nrw
nach hessen da wo die
strukturkonservativen sind und die
versuchen als man bisher eine basis erst
mal gewinnen und dann da oben drauf noch
wahlkampf machen und schüttelte ich an
mich selbst glauben und dieses gefühl
will ich noch leben das schöne ist
gekommen er gleich zu alexanders thema
du hast mir schon verraten ganz so weit
weg gehen wir gleich nicht mit deinem
team habe ich hab auch noch eine
abschlussfrage wenn sie frau ramadani
bevor wir jetzt ihr thema beenden was
müsste armin laschet tun damit sie ihm
ihre stimme doch noch geben als cdu
mitglied
er ist raus
er hat einfach in den letzten jahren
auch gerade wenn zum ein kernthema geht
integration
so viel falsch gemacht in nrw dass ich
glaube es kommt eine sehr große und sehr
aktive integrationsarbeit auf uns zu die
wir vernünftig machen müssen mit neuen
flüchtlingswelle und er ist definitiv
der falsche mann und wenn er wieder so
arbeitet wie in nrw gearbeitet wurde und
immer noch wird dann wird das die
gesellschaft immer mehr spalten deswegen
ist er als kanzlerkandidat eigentlich
umwelt
[Musik]